ie n Clark acting returning officer for
the Somerton and Froome constituency
declare that the total number of votes
cast across the Somerton and Froome
constituency at the UK parliamentary
election on the 8th of June 2017 was
sixty three thousand nine hundred ninety
six the total number of ballot papers
rejected was 104 the total number of
votes given to each candidate was as
follows Mark David Harry Blackburn
Liberal Democrats 13,000 325 Shaun Adam
Dromgoole Labour Party 10,000 998
Richard Thomas hadwin independent 991
Theo Simon Green Party 2347 David John
Warburton the Conservative Party
candidate 36,000 231 therefore I gave
public notice that David John more
burden is duly elected as the Member of
Parliament for the Somerton and Froome
constituency
thank you very much can I first thank
all the officials and all the people
who've worked so hard throughout the
night and the police for keeping us safe
and for facilitating the democratic
process it looks like a rather
extraordinary in perhaps a bit
interesting nights is unfold it
unfolding across the country but once
again I'm deeply honored to be able to
play my part and go to Westminster to
take up a position on the back bench to
fight for our parts of Somerset but I'm
only here because of the efforts of
others and I must thank David Norris my
chairman my agent who's done a great job
and my tremendous association the
legions of volunteers many which are are
here and have been working here tonight
and I must particularly thank David and
Russell who have made the past few weeks
as near to a delight as it's possible
with an election campaign but most of
all I must thank my wife Harriet's who's
coped with all the slings and arrows of
the last few weeks and thank you also to
the other candidates it's again been a
pleasure to work alongside and to get to
know them in what sometimes has been a
rather unpleasant campaign I have to say
unlike the last election the campaign
locally although mostly friendly and
positive has also had an underlying
sense of sneering sort of anger so that
some points of view have been stamped on
and closed down in the name of some kind
of confetti moral outrage only one view
is allowed a different perspective is
morally wrong and so abuse vandalism and
hatred is fully justified and this
sickness leads to a bad place and it
should have no place in today's world I
hope it now dies the death that it
deserves
the last few years I think have seen
enough political division remain errs
and levers labour and conservative now
is becoming very two-party about even
young and old so we must build bridges
and cooperate democratically so we
achieved the best for the future for all
of us I think it's perhaps the greatest
privilege that can be lent to a person
to be asked by local people to represent
them in the House of Commons I will try
to justify that trust thank you